what i would like to do is i'm going to
talk for about hopefully 30 minutes
um because i do want this to be more of
a discussion and have question and
answer
um and what i would like to do is
i will be speaking somewhat formally
somewhat informally i'll try to show
some images
and then leave plenty of time at the end
for questions and answers so what i'd
like to do in some ways is to lay out my
two main arguments that i would like to
make in this talk today
um and then i'm going to provide three
case studies one in guam
one in malaysia and one in hong kong
so first of all eric i really appreciate
your introduction and in many ways it
makes me feel like i succeeded on some
level
because my goal was to tell the story of
the refugee camps
and then sort of what is the actual
politics of the place that hosted the
refugee camps
as many of you know there is a large
literature on vietnamese american
studies
more broadly and in my work i chose not
to focus on the politics of vietnam
or why people left nor do i really look
at resettlement issues whether it's the
united states australia canada or in
europe
instead what i'm interested in how do
the politics
of place matter um in these various
places that hosted the camps
and i would argue that we learn a great
deal about the specificity of who gets
to be a refugee and who doesn't
based on the regional dynamics of that
place so
it made a great job difference if you
were in the philippines versus if you
were in malaysia
or if you were in hong kong and how did
it matter for example for thinking about
malaysia
the politics of mahathir or malaysian
racial politics
versus politics of the marcos era in the
philippines in the 1980s
and so one of my key arguments is that
the dynamics of the local place mattered
refugee status was just not a matter of
what the u.n said or what the united
states said but mattered a lot about the
local politics
of the places that hosted the camps
so that's argument one and i'll just say
briefly i'm not discussing the
philippines in this talk
but i'm very happy to talk about the
philippines as well
um and i i'm really interested in that
so if i don't talk about the philippines
and you're interested in the philippines
please ask questions
secondly i'm also interested in asian
american studies and in critical refugee
studies and so i would like this talk to
be
of interest and value to people who are
interested in southeast asian history
but also to scholars of asian american
studies and those intersections with
refugee studies
and in my book i hope that i show
multiplicity
agency and complexity of the vietnamese
men and women i write about
um very simply and this i think should
be obvious
the individuals i write about were far
from passive they were not abject
they were in fact political actors um i
think i managed to write the book
without ever saying the plight of the
refugee
rather i'm much more interested in the
decisions people were making
how they negotiated how they understood
their time within the camps
whether or not they wanted to then
resettle in the united states
um or another settlement country or even
if they wanted to go back to vietnam
and my story in many ways i think
complicates
um an image of vietnamese refugees which
i think is still focused much
disproportionately on the 1975 migration
and the individuals who resettled after
1975 um well
often not recognizing um the hundreds of
thousands who left after 1975
in the late 70s the 80s and even through
the 1990s
and so by showing those um variations by
thinking about
chinese vietnamese by thinking about
about people who left from northern
vietnam or central vietnam
in relationship to those coming from
southern vietnam i'm hoping to show a
much more complicated story
which i also connect with diasporic
activism
among vietnamese who we settled both in
the united states
as well as in australia so i look at the
intersections
of vietnamese and the camps and
diasporic actors
disproportionately in the united states
but to some extent in australia
as well so those are the two main
arguments and what i would like to do is
begin
by bringing us to where i started this
project
um which was with this image
and i found this image when i was doing
archival research
actually about a different project
related to refugee camps in the united
states
and this is an image of vietnamese in
guam
in 1975 it is a group of vietnamese as
probably most of you in this zoom room
know approximately a hundred thousand
vietnamese leave at the end of the u.s
war
um and the majority of these men and
women come to the united states
canada or france and what i did not know
was that most of them go to guam first
in some ways if you think about it makes
sense that you don't just show up
from a boat in saigon to california
but the united states brought most of
these individuals to guam
for screening and most of these
individuals
did in fact want to come to the united
states or a resettlement country
but some did not about 2 000 did not and
i found this image
and i was just like what is going on who
are these men who want to go back to
vietnam
and how are they protesting with this
image of ho chi minh in the background
because what i had learned and sort of
general common sense
is that the majority of vietnamese
americans the united states
um have identified with anti-communism
their debates over images and sort of
the representations of ho chi minh
and so i was really struck by this image
and wanted to know what was going on
and initially i thought i'd find no
documents and that was totally wrong
there's tons of documents about this
and this in many ways came to my my
research questions
and in this image we had men who wanted
to go back to vietnam and did not want
to resettle in the united states
so just quickly to locate where we are
guam
is right here it's in the pacific it's
actually not
part of southeast asia it's part of the
pacific islands it is quite
far from southeast asia um but the
united states brought vietnamese
from southern vietnam to guam for
staging this is largely because
guam um is a u.s colony or
territory it is four thousand miles from
hawaii
it's almost six thousand miles from
california and it became the primary
staging ground for this 1975 generation
of vietnamese who were trying to leave
the country in the fall of south vietnam
and resettle in the united states and
the united states is able to bring
a hundred thousand people to vietnam to
guam because they do not have to ask
permission
guam again is basically a u.s colony the
united states has
multiple military bases and the guam
government
simply could not say no and so guam
agrees to accept all of these people and
they are on these sort of makeshift
refugee camps
within within guam
and what i learned is that most people
do
go to the united states but about 2 000
choose instead that they made a mistake
that they did not in fact want to move
on so here's an image from these are all
from the pacific daily news which is the
guam newspaper in english
you should know that these do not
represent a tomorrow perspective this is
really sort of a
um an american focused newspaper
um but why did people want to go back
who were these 2
000 who wanted to return to vietnam
um and i would suggest to you
that most of them must stop sharing so i
can see a few
faces most of them were young men
um the assumption is that they'd all
want to come to america but many of
these were young men
about 80 of them were young men who had
been in the south vietnamese navy
but had been only 18 19 years old
and many of them were like on a ship at
sea they were in the navy
so one day saigon falls and the captain
of the ship says
we're not going back to port we're gonna
go to guam
and so these young men found themselves
on guam
and were confused they wanted to go home
they had no interest in going to america
at least not without their families
others were older some had been
separated from their families and so
were unable
to sort of didn't want to continue on
their own and others were elderly people
who decide that in fact they didn't want
to take their chances
in the united states some of their
stories are very striking and i've
written
about this in some detail the most
traumatic is a group of officers
who flew airplanes out of saigon to
thailand
and could not go back to vietnam
unbeknownst to them
and the u.s actually there's good
documentation that they were drugged
and put onto airplanes and brought to
guam and so these men
felt as if they were kidnapped right
that they did not mean to
to flee and so on guam
these and it is disproportionately men
most of the people protesting were
men there are some women but much
smaller numbers and they want to go back
to vietnam
and so they begin protesting and these
protests begin to escalate
and the united states honestly doesn't
know what to do with them they don't
want to force them to come to the united
states
they also don't really know how to bring
them back to vietnam
and the romanian government wants them
off the romanian government
is like we don't need this headache who
are these people you said this was going
to be brief and
now people are burning down buildings
and marching up and down
i just want to show you some of these
images i was not actually able to
include these in the book
because they're from the pacific daily
news um
it was the rights were too complicated
but the images are remarkable
here's one of the individuals who still
who left the airplane he did not want to
come
and you begin to see images of people
protesting with english language signs
you can see they're familiar with
english many of them had worked with the
us military
you get images like this one where the
repatriates walk out
and protest um hunger strikes
hunger strike until die
they burn down buildings on the bases
and eventually the us government
gives in for lack of a better word and
says fine
you can go back to vietnam and we're
going to give you your own
ship to return on and they give them
this commercial vessel the tung tin one
and they tell that these young men the
repatriates
that they can return and here's an image
that really stood with me of them sort
of
celebrating this return in this image i
think you can really see the youth
of these men they were really quite
young
you can see i think in this image of
their sense of joy
that they are going home and the goal is
that they will return to vietnam
they do return this is um october of
1975.
here again is an image of the ship and i
have the great honor of working with
trend and true
and my colleague bakwa tran to translate
a vietnamese memoir about the ship that
returned to vietnam
um in some ways quite tragically
um and i think this might not surprise
anyone in this room
the vietnamese government was not
sympathetic towards this group of
repatriates
they saw them as potential cia agents as
suspect
as potential infiltrators um did not
take them at their word
and they were brought to re-education
camps um when they returned in 1975
and in particular the author i worked
with trans and true was in prison for 12
years
um and so very traumatic experiences
but why do i find this story so
compelling and how did it bring me on
this journey through the book
first of all i think it's important that
we begin the story in guam
and do you think guam's politics matter
matters that it was a colony
and matter that guam could not say no to
the united states
it mattered that guam had this network
of u.s military bases
because of the history of u.s militarism
on guam
and yet it's also important to recognize
that the romanian politicians
did try to do their best to manage the
situation
they felt responsible to both guomanians
chamorros as well as american military
personnel
and they were trying to come up with a
way to navigate
both the pressures they had on them from
the us government
and the pressures that they had from
these vietnamese repatriates
secondly i think it shows a very dynamic
story of activism and one
in an unexpected place so here we see a
group of vietnamese
who are mobilized who recognized their
ability to create
pressure on the us government and on the
romanian government
and seek to in fact direct their own
goals which in their case was not coming
to the united states
but rather was returning to vietnam and
thirdly i think it's a really
complicated story
because there's a part of me that wants
to in many ways celebrate
their activism and celebrate their sort
of political acumen
and yet their story is one which is
tragic in multiple ways
because when they return um they are
imprisoned and they're seen as suspect
and many then do come to the united
states in the late 70s and early 80s or
through the odp or because they leave
later
but it is not a story where um
they triumph in many ways it is a much
more ambivalent story
and one that i think demonstrates that
they did not know what was going to
happen
um and i think in many ways i think of
trend and true
he talked about leaving northern vietnam
in 1954 never seeing his family again in
north vietnam that was his experience
when he moved south
so when he thought when he was separate
from his wife that he would never see
her again
that was a real feeling um and it was
legitimate and that he did not realize
when he returned
um quite how long he would be imprisoned
or the trauma that that would inflict
upon him or his family
he does come to the united states um in
the 90s and i had the good fortune of
meeting him
so that is where the story begins and so
the key points are one
the politics of guam and second the
questions of activism
and third the complexities so with that
i want to turn to my next case which is
that of malaysia
and malaysia i'm going to show you the
map again
here we go so if we come here and we go
to malaysia and i also see my colleague
quantron
um here um i know you've done a great
deal of really fantastic work in
malaysia i hope we can talk afterwards
as well
but for those of you less familiar maybe
with the geography here we have malaysia
malaysia's two parts peninsula malaysia
and eastern malaysia
um we have saba here that's partially
important by story because we have
filipino refugees coming into sabah as
well
at the same time and we have a large
number of vietnamese and this is the era
which um in the west from americans and
in english language
newspapers often we start referring to
the boat people
this will be large numbers of vietnamese
leaving um this
is after some of the re-education camps
um
really some people in the late 70s you
also have the vietnamese government
um having more collectivization sending
people to new economic zones
and this leads people to leave vietnam
and as you can hear see here south
vietnam um people either went to
thailand
or to malaysia so you can see here the
geography was
the closest proximity and
at this moment the largest group of
malay
uh malaysia people go to this island in
pulaobi dong which is in trenganu
um which is a couple hours away from
kuala lumpur
um in some ways in a sort of regional um
the northeastern region of malaysia
um and what i would say in this case
which i find quite
interesting as again thinking about the
malaysian politics
and how this fits into our story
so in the united states um u.s
politicians saw all vietnamese as
anti-communists as quote deserving there
is there's clearly anti-refugee
sentiment in the united states as well
as anti-asian politics
but rhetorically they're often framed um
as anti-communists and in some ways
deserving of us aid but this was not the
way it was seen in malaysia and i think
that malaysia
plays a really complicated role on the
one hand it offers refuge to thousands
tens of thousands of vietnamese
and yet on the other hand they begin
casting people off to sea
um pushing boats away off to indonesia
which really
results in thousands of people drowning
um and
ends up having a very harsh policy
towards these vietnamese boats
um so there's a real conflicted
relationship on this island would be
dong the conditions are quite
difficult and complicated um i had the
good fortune of being able to go
to palabidong about a year ago this is
um
today these are the archival images from
the 1970s
see some images in the chat oh yes thank
you thank you for
putting up quan's article it's fantastic
um
and here we have um again
images from palau bidong but one of the
things that i wanted to talk about is
how did malaysia see these vietnamese
differently than the united states
and one thing that is notable is that a
disproportionate number of these
vietnamese were um chinese vietnamese
and this is notable because in malaysia
this meant that they were seen
differently than they were either in
hong kong or in the united states
this is because malaysia has a um a
population
which is about 40 malay about 20 to 30
chinese ethnicity and about 10 to 50
south asian
and what this mean is that
there is a way in which in malaysia
these incoming vietnamese
were seen as chinese
and it meant that in malaysia there was
anxiety about them
actually bringing communism with them to
malaysia and from the united states
point of view this would seem
counterintuitive these are individuals
who are fleeing a communist country
right
these are individuals who generally
narrate their experiences
as being anti-communists and yet the
malay
newspapers malay texts often
their xenophobia took a lens of
anti-chineseness
and also anti-communism so if we think
today about the ways in the united
states for example
um syrian refugee politics can often
come into this idea of seeing
seeing syrians as terrorists even though
the syrians are fleeing
terrorist acts here we see something
similar where we see
chinese vietnamese somehow being blamed
or associated
with the very government that they are
trying to leave
i just want to give you a few examples
so for example
in mastica which was a malay language
newspaper that was very popular in
malaysia at the time
that they would argue that rather than
seeing
the malaysia's anti-communist haven it
said that they suspected that the
communist agents were going to go and
make contacts with the malaysian
communist party
and the new straight times explicitly
said that this was essentially their
fear
the far eastern economic review reported
that the government feared hanoi was
intentionally quote
planting agents among the so-called
refugees
there was a letter to the editor in the
far eastern economic review
that said the communist underground in
peninsular malaysia
led by qin peng was and still is
dominated by the chinese
the idea that chinese are communists is
embodied in the minds of the malays
they form an equation chinese equals
communists
chinese equals refugees therefore
refugees equals communists
and the government argued for constant
vigilance and it even suggested that
many of those quote who were running
away
had supported the viet cong and so there
was this i would say real ambivalence on
the one hand i actually
want to um recognize that malaysia took
in tens of thousands of people
right and in a moment when we see
countries around the globe
including in terms of particularly the
united states refusing refugees
malaysia actually did face a fair deal
of burden
taking in large numbers of people on the
other
hand there was a great deal of
xenophobia which i think we see in
almost any nation state
and in addition the sort of rhetoric of
fear about the vietnamese as
infiltrating malaysia that's why they
should be kept on palabidong
and islands we don't want to let them
associate with malaysians
okay and this will lead to in many ways
malaysia's much harsher policy but they
begin instituting
which is pushing these boats off to sea
um and again this
results in and people both dying and and
great deals of trauma
and will lead to mahathir's comments um
prime minister
um muhammad mahathir who becomes
probably the most important malaysian
politician
of the 20th century and into the 21st
he is still the deputy um prime minister
at this point
and he says in 1979 our patience is
fully
extended if 500 000 immigrants try to
land in britain
they might probably shoot them we've
already been accused by newsweek of
shooting illegal immigrants
so we might as well do it and justify
their accusations
we are tired of being nice and humane
and what do we get
nothing so why bother mahathir's
frustration broke all polite or
diplomatic pretenses
and the new york times reported that
shoot on site legislation could be
forthcoming his strong words succeeded
in capturing international attention
gaining
sort of momentum and forcing along with
hong kong and great britain
the unhcr to come up with a new formula
that would grant
vietnamese rights to first asylum
i think this is interesting because
malaysia is an independent country
which had been a colony is trying to
both assert its national sovereignty
is trying to in some ways throw the
language of humanitarianism back
at the west and is trying to negotiate
um essentially how to maintain control
over its borders
um even as it both is providing support
and the red crescent society provides a
great deal of support for the vietnamese
in the camps
as well as in many ways going alongside
the malay chauvinism that is very much
sort of apparent
in malaysian politics this will result
in the 1979 unhcr conference in geneva
and this will create a framework which
will provide
refugee status and first asylum status
for vietnamese
who land in first asylum countries from
1979 to 1989.
it's essentially a three-part agreement
first
vietnam will start preventing vietnamese
from leaving so easily
and it will also start what's called the
orderly departure program
which will allow vietnamese to leave
from vietnam
that program doesn't really get going
through the late 80s but it gets sort of
started in 1980 79 1980 um and it's
actually i think one of the missing
things in my book i think there's a
great book to be written about the odp
and hopefully someone in this group
might be doing that
secondly it said the first asylum
countries will
accept vietnamese they will not push
them off
this doesn't mean it totally stops it
does keep happening
but at least in principle there will be
first asylum
and secondly it says that the united
states
europe resettlement countries will
accept everyone who shows up in the
camps they will all get resettled in a
third country
okay that's the 1979 agreement
finally at this point the last thing i
want to add before turning to hong kong
is we begin to get vietnamese activism
and oh goodness here we go we begin to
get vietnamese activism i like this
image here this is a group of vietnamese
americans
advocating for support of this 1979
agreement
and you began to have organizations like
iraq which was the indochina
research action committee lobbying the
un
you begin to have groups like both
people sos
becoming active in refugee politics and
recognizing that if they wanted to be
able to protect vietnamese who want to
leave the country
that they would be able they needed to
start sort of finding power
and that was both through the united
nations and through the united states
and so these groups both iraq and both
people sos
begin lobbying both the un and u.s
politicians
um and we see this emerging in the late
1970s
and this is just an image from again my
most recent trip and again quan has
written much more about this
um this was a i found this a really
moving memorial on palabidong
um someone has been recently instead of
a solar-powered
um musical apparatus so when you go
through this memorial you actually hear
um music
even though um it is generally
unpopulated
okay last point before we turn to
questions hong kong
okay key points about malaysia
malaysians malaysian sovereignty
specificities of malaysian politics
beginnings of diasporic activism
okay hong kong so this is a map i think
karina this might even be one of the
maps that you and i both use this is um
one of the maps of the various camps
within hong kong
um i'm gonna actually this is from the
artwork from uc irvine and this is also
from the university of california irvine
um
archive i'll show you the images at the
end so why hong kong
hong kong becomes a key site in the late
1980s
and again i think that we see here why
the politics of place
matter hong kong is a british colony and
again it was
north of vietnam so you got a large
larger number of people from northern
vietnam
coming to hong kong this will make a big
difference to how refugees or the
vietnamese are seen in hong kong
because they are coming from northern
vietnam but hong kong is british
and so british colonialism they're
supposed to be humanitarian
there's a lot of pressure on hong kong
um they're very proud that they do not
push boats off the way the malaysians
did but they do put the vietnamese in
camps
but from 1979 to 1988
um hong kong accepts all the vietnamese
coming
and all the vietnamese who show up in
hong kong um
get refugee status and again a lot of
this um karina has done work
on this as well and you might want to
add in later karina um when we have a
conversation
so we have large numbers coming to hong
kong
what happens though is that hong kong's
politics are again specific
two things more than two but two i want
to mention make hong kong really
different
one if you are chinese and you want to
come to hong kong
in 1985 you're deported you're sent back
so if you are a hong kong chinese person
and your cousin comes over from shanghai
illegally undocumented you got sent back
so that meant a lot of people in hong
kong were like wait a second
why do the vietnamese get to stay why
did they get resettled
if my spelta from china doesn't get to
why not
why do these vietnamese get this special
treatment
secondly hong kong is going to become
china
in 1997. so is this pressure on hong
kong
um to navigate this sort of transition
from the british
to chinese sovereignty and hong kong
doesn't have a lot of
sort of independent power and what i
argue
is that by changing the policy visa via
the vietnamese
it is a way for hong kong politicians to
assert their own agenda
at a moment where they don't have a lot
of control and so that that
really shapes what would become the fate
of these vietnamese in the late 1980s
so what happens a lot happens
in 1988 hong kong
basically rips up the unhcr accord they
say
too many people are coming and really
importantly this brings in the united
states
the united states is not resettling
these people the united states says
these people are from north vietnam
they're not south vietnamese they're not
really refugees
and so they're not our problem and the
british don't take them the british said
we've taken 10 000 people
not our problem and so hong kong is
saying well what are we gonna do then
um and so you should know that the
united states in many ways sort of
passes the buck um in a way and avoids
responsibility
in hong kong the politicians say then
fine
then we're going to change we can't take
this anymore we need to change this
policy
otherwise people are going to be in
camps for years and we're going to have
china
here in the next 10 years we need a
change and the change is this
you'll no longer automatically be a
refugee instead you will become an
asylum seeker
and we will interview you and if you can
prove to us
that you really are a refugee then yes
you can be resettled in the united
states or canada or australia
but if you cannot prove that if we think
you are simply poor
or we think your story's too confusing
or we think that
you weren't prosecuted or persecuted
enough then you will be repatriated
and we will send you back to vietnam
at first the united nations is really
opposed to this they say no
that's wrong we can't be doing that we
can't be sending people back
but under serio vieira which is actually
really interesting sierra vieira de
mello
um he becomes an important person in the
united nations he actually dies
tragically in iraq
um they say actually we think this is a
good idea
and the u.n turns around and says we are
going to embrace this new model
and they come up with dates they're
different in hong kong than they are in
the other southeast asian countries
but after these cut-off dates you will
no longer be a refugee
you will have to make your case and if
you can't you will be sent back to
vietnam
and this leads to massive both legal
and political protests in the camps in
hong kong
this also happens in malaysia as well
but i focused my research on hong kong
and there's a way in which i argue here
that there is a
clash between what the hong kong
government
like to see as humanitarian policies and
credentials
of sort of safe harbor and what
vietnamese american activists argued
was a violation of their human rights
and so you can see
here really a contrast between these two
this will lead to a great deal of
activism within the camps
let me share my screen here again um
this will lead to both
political activism you'll get lots of
protests like this one
and for me also this image versus the
one in guam are really striking
sort of similar protests but for
different ends these vietnamese are
protesting both against the screening
many thought the screening itself was
wrong they would themselves believe
themselves to be refugees
and secondly against repatriation they
do not want to be sent back to vietnam
these are images largely from the
english language hong kong newspapers
we are victims of the hong kong
screening
here we again we see the hong kong
security forces
entering these camps this leads to very
violent showdowns within the camps this
is in the late 90s in the white house
detention centers
um these will become massive
demonstrations where again vietnamese
will protest often
very physically with their bodies um
through hunger strikes through
self-mutilation through attacks
um arguing that they themselves are
refugees and do not want to go back
this artistic representation here are
forced
deportations or repatriations
in addition and these are really
traumatic images um
and there's even more of this this
archive is vast and again karina's done
a great job both of documenting those
stories
and of showing both images and video
in addition alongside this we get a lot
of activism
from dice sport vietnamese americans and
vietnamese australians
so you begin to have groups for example
uc irvine is a large center vietnamese
american community
so project noc as well as other groups
begin to send volunteers
to work with vietnamese and hong kong
they provide english classes and art
classes
you also get lawyers so you begin to
have americans
send lawyers to hong kong to help
advocate for the vietnamese within the
camps
they are fairly successful um but not in
a grand way right so they have
individual cases but they don't get the
policy changed
you also get groups like both people sos
that's transformed from groups that
actually saved people at sea
to a really um strong lobbying
organization in northern virginia
that is able to get bipartisan support
but really a lot of support from
the republican congress members to try
to again prevent repatriations
or to provide more avenues for
vietnamese to be resettled in the united
states
so i'm interested in this diasporic
activism and then networks between the
activism in the camps
as well as within the united states and
then australia
and so what happens in the end in the
end um
about 60 000 people from hong kong are
deported about 30
000 more people from other camps
throughout southeast asia are also
repatriated
so the numbers are really large almost
100 000 people are in the end
repatriated um i think the story is
really important though for the same
reasons
one place matters it mattered that you
had a chinese majority
it mattered that you were a british hong
kong was a british colony
it matters in 1997 it was looming
for these hong kong politicians and so
the politics of hong kong are radical
they're not worried about the vietnamese
being communists
like the malaysians were rather they are
their own set of concerns and that
shaped their policies
secondly we again see activism the
vietnamese were extremely organized
extremely um strategic
and how they were creating both legal
and political campaigns
to prevent repatriation and also
creating strategic alliances with
vietnamese
already in the west okay so those are in
some ways the main
points um where to end i just want to
add
that these are obviously stories that
still matter today and i just want to
end with a few last images
um there are stories just from two years
ago many in this zoom room are probably
familiar with these
um but the trump administration has
begun deporting vietnamese
who came in the 80s and 90s many who
then i mean came into
contact with the law were not able to
become u.s citizens
and has been proactively deporting very
vulnerable population that had often
been the united states for 10 15
20 years this has again led to
vietnamese diasporic activism
this was from about two years ago hear
my politics i like this one
forget trump um from a recent um
vietnamese american protest
um against these deportations um
and i think that with the united states
in many ways using mexico
as a place to keep refugees right now um
we see
the ways in which wealthy countries
have acted to keep people outside of
their borders
and i think that we need to be much more
attention to places like mexico and
turkey
that have been holding these large
numbers of refugees um
as we understand refugee politics today
so i've gone a little bit over but we
have about 15-20 minutes i hope um
people found that interesting and i
would
um love to hear your questions or
comments or arguments or critiques
thank you jana um take a moment and
applaud this wonderful presentation
um i will take on the role
of uh moderator um
so that will allow janna to pay
attention to the speakers and the
questions that are asked so what i
propose
is that if you have a question you use
the hand raising function
on zoom you can go down in the
participant section and raise your hand
and i'll try to keep track of you
if for some reason you're having trouble
with the hand raising function
and you can't get my attention you
realize that i haven't seen you
um just please send a chat to the
everyone
part of the chat so that you say that
you have a question or you can even post
the question and then we'll allow janet
to read it
and answer it um so let me start by
calling on anyone does anyone want to
start off our q a
and and also please keep your questions
relatively short so that we can allow as
many people as possible
to ask questions and i should also add
that the
the event officially ends at one o'clock
but i'll stick around
i'll keep the zoom window open for
another 15 minutes after that if you
have
extra questions um so who would like to
start
um we'll start with quan
hi jana thank you so much for your
amazing talk and congratulations on the
book
um i was very struck in the so i just
finished a book over the summer
and i thought you know the the temporal
coverage
of the book um was really expansive and
it really takes our understanding of
refugees kind of beyond an
ascending and host country kind of
relationship
and so i really think the conversation
about right thinking about refugee camps
is sites that are
often transit but
here you're centering these sites so i'm
wondering
um if you could say a little bit more
about you know thinking of
camp as an analytic um and
and how might these kind of you know
forgotten or abandoned sites
um help us recenter interstate
relationships
now that is a wonderful question and
thank you so much and thank you for your
work as well i just want to tell you
how much i enjoy your work um i guess
for me
and this in some ways brings me back
there's a way in which
my work might seem to not make sense and
i wrote a book about cuba
and now i'm bouncing over to southeast
asia and so what am i doing
um but the link actually is the analytic
of camps because if you think
about the ways and this is how i'm
thinking about the ways in which i write
about guantanamo and i write about the
naval base in guantanamo bay
and i'm trying to think about how do
spaces that seem peripheral and marginal
actually become central to imperial
politics
and i think that empires use places that
seem to be out of the way um but in fact
magnify both the extent of their power
and the limits
right and so i like playing with those
tensions
um and i think that there's a way in
which militaries very clearly
understand this if we think about where
military bases are located
they understand the value of both being
on the periphery
um or places that might be missed but
yet seems still important i'm thinking
about like bases like
diego garcia and the indian ocean um or
if we think about
where you know their point of camp so i
think that there's a way
in which thinking more about networks of
power and the relationship between
empires and local communities
the camps become places where those
tensions become visible
and where we can see the ways in which
governments both try to have state
control
and then also in some ways the limits of
those control in a place
like the camp so i hope that helps
answer your question but that's where i
see my guantanamo work
really in some ways reverberating
analytically
even if it's not there in the archives
uh thanks for the great answer next
question will be from
john at the university of connecticut
hi um thank you for the presentation
that was really interesting
my question is about how the politics
of the refugees differed
due to the composition of the refugees
you talked about how there are more
northerners
in hong kong versus more southerners and
some of the other camps i was also
thinking that
in the later years more there are more
people who are actually just there for
like a short period of time who are
transiting through his odp and not
actually
vote people and and the other reason i'm
asking this is because i noticed that in
the picture from hong kong there are
people using the rbn flag the south
vietnamese flag
so i was just wondering if like the
symbols or the arguments or
or the you know the tensions within the
refugee politics differed by location
because of the composition of the
camp population you know it's a really
good question
um and i don't think my answer is as
good um in some ways the
south vietnamese flag is used repeatedly
because i think it's a legible
symbol and so for the people protesting
they want to be seen as refugees and so
the south vietnamese flag
is valuable in that way and i'm not
trying to um
underestimate their actual affinity with
the flag my guess is most the time it
was strong
but it's a useful symbol what i think
is um notable i mean i'm looking over to
korean on this side but
there's a lot of tension between the
north vietnamese and the south
vietnamese and actually i think this is
an area for more research and this is
where the fact that i don't speak
vietnamese
i'd be really clear i not a vietnamese
language speaker or reader
matters and where i think someone who
does know vietnamese could do more work
um a lot of time that the sort of
anger and the um there's there's
physical fighting between the north
vietnamese and south vietnamese the hong
kong
camps this is often um attributed to
um regional tensions and i think what i
think of my hunch and i and again maybe
some of the vietnamese could do more i
think that's true i also think though
that it is true
that the north vietnamese resented that
the south vietnamese were seen as
refugees
that it was easier if you were south
vietnamese to get refugee status
so there are both maybe lingering
tensions vis-a-vis the actual conflicts
between north and south vietnam but
there was also i think um
anger about who was seen as a refugee
the other that i would only add is that
and i think um
john christensen knudson has written a
great deal about this and this idea of
the screening machine as yen lee
is spiritu but there was a need to tell
a certain story like in any refugee
context
and the right story was my father was in
the south vietnamese military
i was discriminated against because i
was from south vietnam my father was in
a re-education camp
and that story was a story that people
would tell because it was effective
and what that does is it minimized other
stories so just quickly one story that i
really found emotive or
compelling was one that didn't fit which
was a story of
a north vietnamese man who went to um
like east germany
like on a work program when he was there
he got involved with independent union
politics
so he gets deported from east germany
and sent back to north vietnam
and then he gets some problems there and
so they send him to hong kong
he actually fit the definition of an
anti-communist refugee
but because he'd been to east germany
and was from northern vietnam and was a
union
activist it didn't look right and so
i think the symbols are being used
strategically as well sometimes although
not to
um underestimate people's actual
affinities either
karina wants to jump in for a second
oh is it okay for me to say something
now yes
do you mind letting karina jump in real
quick go ahead
thank you karine yeah i just want to add
into this particular
conversation about north vietnamese and
south vietnamese in the camp
i was in the refugee camp in indonesia
and we didn't have this problem with
vietnamese fighting among
each other as much as hong kong and
when you were talking about the north
vietnamese being
resentful towards south vietnamese
because they were not considered as
refugees
and interestingly south vietnamese in
the camp also resent the fact that
because of the north they think
because of the north vietnamese that put
them into
the at risk of gaining refugee status
and also the south vietnamese who were
stuck in the
cameron hong kong blaming the north
communists because of you guys now i
lost country i got to escape and i'm
stuck here
so that's already have that political
tension between them
and of course um different cultures
different values and and the way they
um that their lifestyle of north
vietnamese and south vietnamese are so
different
and because of the fights that they
constantly have is actually put the
vietnamese refugees in a disadvantaged
situation
because the hong kong residents were
saying that
we host you here we provide you safety
we give everything to you but you burn
down the cam you are causing problems
um so eventually the hong kong
residencies
they protest more toward the government
and send
do not accept any more vietnamese
refugees so that's another layer
of pressure that the hong kong
government had to deal with
right thank you karina it's a trend
uh thank you so much for your wonderful
book talk professor lipman
um so i am thinking a lot about what you
said about mexico and i'm also thinking
to
like the camps in europe like for
example morya which just burned down two
two weeks ago and it never really
occurred to me to think of camps in like
guam and hong kong as sites of
like liminality but also agency but the
thing is the reception of refugees
like vietnamese refugees and southeast
asian cold war refugees was quite
different than what's going on today
and i know that's just one facet of it
so you know thinking to your work across
countries like in cuba
like how do you understand like the
difference
in response to like efforts to advocate
self-advocate for
resettlement and such no i mean so i
think that's exactly right and
so i don't want to be nostalgic for the
cold war you know i mean like
but on the on the other hand the cold
war
put pressure on places like the united
states and great britain to accept
people
and a way that our current government
does not feel external pressure to do so
um and so i think that we are dealing
with um
far more fraught situations in some ways
than
cubans or vietnamese did in the 70s 80s
and 90s
i think when i was doing my research
i'm very critical of the hong kong
government in the book in multiple ways
although i also am somewhat sympathetic
to the pressures that they faced
and there's a way in which they keep
being worried that if they push people
off people won't think of them as being
humanitarian and they're supposed to be
british
and they can't do x because they have to
be seen as humanitarian
i was like oh my goodness if only our
country still felt
pressure to look good um things would be
at least a little bit better
and that sort of need to at least have a
facade
of humanitarianism even that is gone and
i
think that that sort of erasure or
political
sort of stance that we don't even need
to pretend to be protecting human rights
anymore
is a huge shift um from the cold war to
the post-cold war age
that a country like the united states
and arguably even like countries in and
western europe
no longer even have to pretend that they
care about human rights humanitarianism
in a way that some of the pressures both
of colonialism on
england as well as on um the united
states for the cold war
created at least a need to
pay more than a little bit more than lip
service and that is
no longer even the case so i think the
situation right now is really grim i
think
um the vietnamese and many of them were
sent back i mean i'm not again trying to
underestimate that
but the the today people have even fewer
avenues
because the legal system's been um
monopolized by
um conservative administrative judges
um now it's time for a question from
peter
presley lipman i have a question um in
regards to the malaysian case example
um so um at the time you know were there
local chinese malay political parties
organizations bodies whatsoever and what
have you
who advocated for these chinese
um coming into the country or did they
say oh no we don't want anything to do
with
them so that's a really good question um
i
tried to do some research on that and i
found less than i would have thought but
even that silence i think is interesting
so i would again say that's an area
where i think there should be more
research and again with someone whose
language skills
are better than mine i was in malaysia
for several weeks i had a research trans
a translator who could speak both
chinese and mla so we looked at a lot of
chinese newspapers and chinese
malaysian newspapers to see what were
the chinese political parties saying
right because there are several chinese
political parties in malaysia
some that were affiliated with the
government and some that were in the
opposition and there was
actually remarkably little in the
chinese language newspapers at the time
um and in fact the malay newspapers
commented
on the chinese language newspaper
silence and it
seems to me that there was a reluctance
to support the chinese vietnamese
because
it would have been politically unpopular
um and they were
in some ways concerned about not being
seen as nationalist
enough right they want to be seen as
being malaysian nationalist
and not sort of specific towards the
chinese vietnamese
um there are leaders who do talk about
humanitarianism they are often against
the government's desire to push people
off
um but i would say there was actually
much i thought there was gonna be a lot
more in the chinese language newspapers
in malaysia
and in fact there was a lot more in the
malay language newspapers
than there was in the chinese i would
only add and this is where someone like
karina's work and their other um
oral history collections what i did find
instead though
was in vietnamese oral histories
people would say oh um a chinese
malaysian like
met me on the shore and helped me out or
oh someone so and so met me and they
helped me get to the right place and so
there seemed to be sort of at a personal
level
um some connections and they often both
spoke um
sometimes they shared a chinese language
sometimes not malaysians
generally speak a different chinese
dialect than the
than cantonese but in any case there
were some moments
where there in the oral histories these
moments of connection would come
together
but i found most chinese that the
chinese language press was much
quieter on this topic than i had
anticipated
uh we'll turn to tiffany
tiffany you need to unmute briefly oh
you're still muted
all right um well i was saying that
thanks so much to janna for putting
together such a wonderful book that
provides invaluable resources
um for those of us who want to learn
about this exodus history
um and i you know i came across um
the at the unhcr archives i came across
a number of documents talking about
people in 1975
wanted to repatriate but i never really
follow up on that
but it's so wonderful and really
exciting to
um to actually read your book and
learned about that
in more detail and i also appreciate
your the way you navigate the
sensitivity of terminology
especially whether to call all
vietnamese
refugees as a lot of humanitarian groups
would advocate for for me it just
the sake of identifying different
periods and
how policy changes in southeast asia in
hong kong and with the unhcr as well
that we have to make that clear
so i really like the way you navigated
that
now my question is um in terms of the
title
um in cams i mean i understand that in
vietnamese language they call
everything jai means kim
but with the case of hong kong um
i you know i was with a group of
vietnamese that got recital in hong kong
for three years
and i i listened to the way they used
the term
and it has always been very separate
because there there were a number of um
detention centers that hosted the
vietnamese refugees
and this is including victoria prison
that turned into
tycoon contemporary art that i worked
at like a few years ago so
most of them called jai gum
to refer to detention center and jai
dinam to refer to refugee camp
and jaikum also you know i think the
term
came about in 1982 when hong kong
started to enforce
closed camp policy even admitting
vietnamese as refugees
there was still like a closed camp
policies in
so the vietnamese would not be able to
move around
freely so how how did you navigate
around this kind of like landmine to
come up with the title
in cam now that's a really good question
and in some ways i think is also a
really valuable critique
um i guess i would say a few things one
is
that you are first of all correct
they're not all camps they don't have
barbed wire i mean
there's and in palau and there's no
barbed wire even a lot of times right in
the philippines these are open places
where people would work outside
and it was very different i think that i
chose the title in some ways
because i wanted to be raising the
questions that quan asked earlier
about sort of the idea of the camp
um and thinking about these spaces where
people
were before resettlement and bef after
they left
and so i think that you're right that in
some ways it may be
too simplistic or um
catchy um but sort of sort of lies these
are larger sort of both linguistic and
political ideas
but the reason i guess i landed on it
because
it was able to bring together all the
multiple stories
that i was trying to tell from guam to
malaysia to hong kong to the philippines
and even if it is not as precise a term
as potentially
it should be it allowed me to make the
argument in the title
that the book is about why we must think
about these places in between
and why that is necessary for actually
understanding refugee politics
so i i take your points really seriously
um but i guess from my point of view it
did some of the
analytical work that i wanted it to do
by bringing the stories together
i think it's a good like
all-encompassing kind of term
like when you use the word cam because
that when you can also critique
these refugee places actually military
bases
and cam so i i do see the point
thank you yeah no thank you
great question um i want to flag to
everyone that it's one o'clock
for those of you who had appointments
that needed to leave but we were
we'll go into extra time um as if it's a
exciting soccer match um so we'll we'll
go into extra time now and i have a
question from
ivan small so ivan
thanks johnner for really interesting
talk and for an interesting book i
picked it up and started reading it i
just had a quick question i was curious
uh are are there many people in the
vietnamese diaspora that are interested
in
returning to these camps um and kind of
you know
using these camps as a site of
collective memory um you mentioned
uh help and and palawan
there was kind of an effort there under
father vien um but
it seemed like that didn't work out so i
was wondering if if there's uh
if there are concerted efforts right now
to to do that yeah no and this is where
kwon has done much more work than i have
um but no they're um not to live
by any stretch of the imagination but as
far as sort of pilgrimage sites
um there are large numbers or i don't
know the sizable numbers of vietnamese
and diaspora the united states can
australia who have gone back to these
places
as pilgrimage sites and karina has also
brought people to the camps and
former sites in indonesia um and
there's a way in which so for example
when i was in malaysia
there um there are temples there's um
statues that are maintained by diasporic
groups
the man who took me to palau bidong
takes vietnamese australian groups
regularly
um and so because i mean many people
died in these camps and in some ways
these camps are places
um where people lost people um that
there is i think a sense of return
there's large numbers of religious
memorials in these camps um
so i think that there's not any interest
in resettlement
you know like father vienne was about
bringing vietnamese americans to help
out at the camps
right into bringing volunteers and then
you have this um
vision this is in the in the philippines
there was an idea the philippines does
not deport people the philippines
resettles a group of vietnamese in the
philippines
and in the end that group doesn't
actually want to stay in the philippines
and most of them also want to come to
the united states
and eventually do as late as 2005.
um but vietnamese americans more um have
gone
um i would think the word pilgrimage is
probably appropriate but if quan or
karina
want to sort of have a different nuance
on it
um be interested in your thoughts but
but not as far as resettling but as far
as there are trips
does that answer your question ivan
yeah thank you okay i don't quality
yeah thanks jenna can i add to that it's
just also you know in terms of
what became of these camps after right
resettlement or repatriation
um so in the cases of indonesia and
malaysia for example
some of those camps or remnants of those
camps continue to be there
um and they've actually turned into like
tourist destinations for
we're not just the refugees who are
returning to visit
as pilgrimage sites but also for local
populations and the kind of laws that
are associated now with these
um forlorn places in some ways and then
in the case of hong kong
or even in thailand you know the traces
of those camps are no longer
physically kind of visible you really
have to dig for it
and there's no concerted effort um to
preserve these sites
on a local level so that also impact the
ability of people
to go back or you know um
and think about on individual levels so
there are people who who do go back
as individuals there are organizations
in the diasporas
um that are kind of spearheading some of
these pilgrimage tours
and so on
marina please join in um yes in
terms of indonesia it's a little bit
unique than the other places
in two ways the the main refugee camp
and galang
became a tourist attraction place you
know mainly for vietnamese
return to visit but for
places where i would like google island
where i was first landed
these were uninhabited islands so
initially there were hundreds of
vietnamese refugees died as soon as we
arrived in the first few months
so more and more vietnamese people
returned to these places um
just to look for the graves of the loved
ones
so that's you know a lot of my work for
refugees focus on these
in uninhabited islands just mainly
looking for
graves of refugees i would
also add to the quan's point in the
philippines it's very different
maybe not that different but the main
camp in the philippines was in bataan
which is the philippine refugee
processing center and that is not part
of my talk
it was very different the philippine
refugee processing center
was for people who had already been
given refugee status
and the united states said well before
you come to america it'll be cheaper for
you to learn english in the philippines
for six months
and then you'll come to the united
states and so people there knew they
were going to get to the united states
or germany or norway's a few people
but that now is a museum and it's
somewhat different because the
philippine government's very proud of
that project
um so some of it actually is also
falling down because they don't have
hundreds of thousands of people there
anymore
but there's also a museum there and evan
espiritu
who also does a lot of this work has
done a film
about the prpc camp
um if there's no objection i'd like to
ask a question
too um i just wanted to add before
asking my own question
that the article i mentioned that kwon
had written
also adds to your story about the
politics within southeast asia
that takes place during the refugee but
also the politics of memorialization
and there's some pretty dramatic stories
that quan relays in that
about um you know the vietnamese
government
interacting with asean and some of the
various countries in order to remove
memorials and the kind of political
pressures that are going on there as
well which is
quite fascinating so the story you tell
is quite
it lingers into the post
exodus period i want to ask a question
that's kind of
um a little bit about how you wrote the
book if you
and i i'll preface it a little bit for
those who haven't read it yet
but um as you heard from the talk
everyone um
the book is organized sort of by
geographically
but at the same time so we have the
different places we have
malaysia we have gua we have gua starts
with guam and there's malaysia then
there's the philippines in hong kong
and so it gives this wonderful
geographic spread of the inter-asian
politics and the different politics of
the different places
but at the same time this is my question
um at the same time janet you layer
kind of a historical chronology on top
so it both
goes kind of geographically but also
goes historically so we start in set
like guam is for 75 malaysia is 75
through
79 and that leads ends up in the unhcr
conference in 79 that's very important
um and then there's the bataan which
over
intersects with people power and the
marcos regime
and aquino and all this stuff and then
there's um
1980 through 89 in hong kong which tells
a different kind of political story
which ends up with this shift
that leads to screening um so my
question for you as a writer right
and as a historian how did you make that
decision
because the camps don't necessarily stop
at the end of the period that you choose
and so i was just curious um
[Music]
what were some of your other options for
structuring the book as you were
imagining it
um and how you settled on this and maybe
some of the challenges that you faced as
you made that choice
yeah oh no thank you so much and thanks
so much for reading it so closely i mean
yeah i mean it's a sprawling book
and it you're right so there's a way in
which
i stopped writing about malaysia in 1979
but of course there are vietnamese in
malaysia until the mid-90s
right um and so it doesn't quite work
that way i guess i decided
that there were um
i thought it was about my first book
somebody's like this that i like
thinking both thematically and
chronologically and i was trying to
figure out which were the stories i
wanted
to tell and where was the points where
were the places where those questions
sort of emerged
and i guess archivally what i did is i
had found all this stuff and talk a
little backwards
i found all of the material about guam
and i was like this is an amazing story
i'm gonna run with it
and then after that i didn't really know
what i was doing and i didn't know much
about southeast asia i didn't even know
about the 1989
conference or 79 conference but i went
to geneva
and geneva with the unhcr archives i was
like i'm going to start
here and i'm going to start by looking
at the geneva archives
and from there deciding where i was
going to go so other
critiques of my book i don't deal with
thailand which is actually quite
important as well but it's more
complicated because you have
so many more people from cambodia and
laos um
but there's a way that i started with
the geneva archives
and those archives led me to oh malaysia
is what they're worried about in the 70s
and then hong kong is what they're
worried about in the 80s and 90s
and so in many ways i used that initial
trip to geneva and the unhcr archives to
think about
what is the map both geographically and
chronologically
and in some ways you could argue that
going to geneva first
you know it's going to the capital
rather than going to the sort of as quan
was asking the provinces right so
instead of going
starting with the camps and going inward
i started with the capital
archives and went outward but that
allowed me
to start thinking about the landscape of
the book
and um from there i just had to make
decisions about where and when
and i just decided that i didn't have to
tell the whole story about malaysia
that it was going to be okay that the
stories in hong kong
were more illustrative of that moment of
screening even though there was
screening in malaysia or indonesia
right that answers your question no it
really does and i want to
just respond by saying it wasn't a
critique so much as i was actually
thought it was a very elegant solution
to telling
both the chronological and geographical
story that brought all the politics of
the different places
but then sort of punctuates it with the
significance of a certain place
yeah i thought it was very interesting
um
we're we're at 115 now um we have one
question from francis martin and
there's no objections i'll make that the
last question but if anyone else
um wants to you know send
it out a little bit and you can just
send it to the
also if you have an important question
that you can't squeeze in send it to the
chat so jana has it at her disposal also
just
for her information francis hi dr
littman thank you very much
um for your talk it was wonderful um my
question really again kind of gets to
the
uh history writing side of things how
did language
and your limited access to again
language um vietnamese malay
chinese et cetera sort of narrow or
limit the stories you were able to tell
yeah no absolutely i mean so again
full disclosure and i say this in the
book i am an anglophone i am an american
and i'm not
a good my languages are minimal um
and i actually really struggled with
could i do this project
as an english dominated language project
and i talked to a lot of colleagues and
a lot of friends
and in in a way and i hate to sound like
it's just it's hoods but it's like
you know my i was i was i had tenure my
first book was done i did learn spanish
for the first book
and i just was like i wanted to i want
to follow the stories that i found in
guam
and i found that i'd done other research
in the us that wasn't as compelling to
me
and i was like these are stories that i
felt i could follow
and then i decided that i
was not going to do an oral history
project attached to it that there were
other people who knew vietnamese
and could do those oral history projects
um with language skills that i don't
have and so i draw on karina has done a
lot
university california irvine has a huge
oral history collection
other people have been doing them so i i
largely decided that i was not going to
try to conduct a significant oral
history project i do some interviews i
mean there's
i do some interviews in the project but
that i was going to be cognizant of my
language
limitations i also in some ways going to
express in terms of sites
it should not be too hard to figure out
that i picked sites that were british or
american colonies
that means you have a lot of english
language documents so between guam
malaysia
hong kong and the philippines i would
say the place where the language was the
biggest obstacle would be malaysia
more of the documents there in malay and
chinese in a way that hong kong clearly
if i knew chinese i'd have
access to a whole nother archive but
there's plenty in english
similarly with the philippines um
most of the formal documents in the
philippines are in english so even
though you have
tagalog newspapers or would have been
useful if i spoke
you know visayas or you know at some
point um
that it wasn't necessary from an
archival standpoint
and so i also picked the sites where i
knew
there would be english sources but i
think there's plenty of work to be done
for people with language skills better
than mine and i
i've just decided that it was the book i
wanted to write and that i was able to
find enough english sources and then
hire some translators when i needed them
so i hope that helps
great thanks jana um i think i'm going
to bring this formally to close and stop
the recording
um but i want everyone to join me in
thanking jana for a wonderful talk
you